at last pinnock is nearly failed why
it's only a short matter of time until
we ascend one can only imagine what it
will be like on the other side
initiating final phase
hello d and e ah your lists always with
the lists after all these years I'm
astonished you haven't memorized the
process my apologies Lord Commander but
it is these very list that ensure your
carefully laid plans unfold with such
precision for else in thrall forces
deployed on the ground sources report
that all five factions are nearly
overrun generat technicians are spinning
up the helio phage full power in three
Mac Ron's Burrell see portal opening in
45 microns
tell me spy mistress how many failings
have we witnessed that depends on your
classification Lord Commander do you
mean to count all those that we have
witnessed since the ver LC appeared in
our universe or after our alliance since
I ensure the survival of our people spy
mistress something the Empress would
have never accomplished pinnacle darken
within the hour pen arc will make our
three hundred and first veiling in five
years marked by the Second Battle of
Jenna and your agreement to the passage
and the illustrious beginning of the
generating period so much accomplished
in such a short period of time you do
realize D&E that your list will soon be
of no use our workers nearly complete
pennock will be nothing more than a dark
stain in a matter of microns and soon to
the soulless fall into the dark after
the darkening is complete we will move
the Helio phage to solace immediately
with the current state of the Opposition
our thrall forces on tempest should make
short work of them
all the good it's worth information has
done little to save our world not the
fate of the Empress nor stopped the
darkening of even one of those three
hundred stars from countless stars
billions illuminating the galaxy now
only two left I'm out of time the
passage must not be completed um excuse
me Lord Commander there appears to be a
situation on the ground that I must deal
with personally indeed you must farewell
dnd